every death is very tragic with such a
high death toll how can you say that
your strategy is working well it sounds
like you want to throw us out of EU
Sweden's unique trust based approach to
tackling the corona virus pandemic
rejected the strict lock downs imposed
around the world and instead encouraged
people to voluntarily social distance
but the policy has come under increasing
criticism and pressure a group of
scientists wrote a letter condemning the
approach months ago and more recently
the country's chief epidemiologist
admitted mistakes have been made my
guest this week is Sweden's foreign
minister and Linda with a death toll
much higher than its neighbors and
borders closed due to concerns over the
number of infected has Sweden made a
deadly error
[Music]
foreign minister and Linda welcome to
conflict zone thank you very much you
said recently that Sweden's trust based
strategy to combat the coronavirus was
working your Prime Minister also
continues to maintain the strategy was
the right one but to date you have
nearly 5000 confirmed coronavirus deaths
far higher per capita than your
neighbors who impose stricter lockdowns
early on with such a high death toll how
can you say that your strategy is
working well actually we had the same
goals as most other governments that
says to save life and and health and
also to keep the system in the health
service able to cope with this very
strong push on the limits and actually
we managed to flatten the curve we have
never have problems we getting sick
people into the health care and actually
also we have managed to get our people
to follow the recommendation and we also
have legally binding measures like
social distancing and also watching your
hands don't travel work from home all of
those issues what we have not managed to
do is to keep the virus out of the
elderly care center in specific region
of Stockholm and the surrounding of
Stockholm so I would say that it's a
tragic for each death but it's not
possible to compare with any country
some countries who have had complete
lock downs has far more death tolls than
we have so it's actually no use to do
such comparisons and I want to talk
about that impact on the the elderly
which has been so dramatic in your
country but first I'd like to just pick
up on something that you said because
you said that you've managed to flatten
the curve but we have the European
Center for Disease Control saying the
initial wave of transition transmission
excuse me has passed its peak in all
countries in Europe
except Sweden and Poland what does this
say about your strategy because we're
not even really I would counter what
you're saying there because that is not
true and that was our state
epidemiologist said today that we have
gone far away from the peak we're going
down but two weeks ago we started a
massive testing for virus meaning that
everybody every single person if you
don't even have this light a symptom you
can go and test yourself and of course
that means that we will now have a much
much much greater number of viruses and
that's why it's so wrong just to look at
that situation we don't have any excess
excess of death anymore we have far more
places available when it comes to is
intensive care so it's absolutely what
you look at and to to listen to our
chief epidemiologist this is not the way
that there is a new outbreak or anything
like that so I totally counter what
you're saying you mentioned that the
goal was to save lives slow the rate of
infection about half of the deaths
however have been in homes for the
elderly which you've also highlighted
and those over 70 have accounted for
almost 90% of all deaths 90% of old all
deaths so when you set out those goals
was it just for the young in your
population no we hope that we should be
able to also see to that vulnerable
groups did not get the disease but we
didn't manage to get it out of our
elderly care home and that is something
really have to look into in Sweden many
elderly care home is privately owned
there is a lot of precarious work there
is also a lot of people working there
who don't even have a monthly salary
they are only there per hour
many of those didn't stay home when they
have slight symptom and this is
something that we in Sweden
what is your to be able to
to evaluate later what was your level of
responsibility though because we have
the former state epidemiologist Anna
Kalinda saying the following about your
your handling of this she says there was
no strategy at all for the elderly I now
understand that I do not understand how
they can stand and say the level of
preparedness was good when in fact it
was lousy was there no plan for the
elderly
well changeful isn't it well it's your
word I think that you are actually
acting like this this kind of a World
Cup in who get the disease or not get
the disease we don't see it that way
that's not how responsible government is
handling those issues actually what we
have in Sweden is another way of
governmental organization we have very
much on local level and doula care is
taking care of regional level the
hospital care is taken care of and then
we have the central level with very
small ministries and very big
authorities and that means that if it's
not working on one of the levels then we
will have a problem and that is why the
state had to go in and take a lot of
decision when we saw what was happening
in the local Iran and mostly privately
run elderly care homes that means for
example that we have taken more than 40
different ordinance and also several new
laws so that the central level could be
able to go in and decide also in other
levels and now we could see that the
disease and the transmission of the
virus is actually going down in the
elderly care but for example the the
regional Organization for regional and
local authorities stated that there was
more than 40 percent of those who were
employed that didn't have enough
knowledge of
basically hiding care for example how
you were shy and and so on and so forth
that is now been taking care of what
140,000 having got an education so let's
take a deeper look at why this happened
in the elderly care care homes because
there have been these horrific reports
from news outlets that not everything
has been done to save the lives of the
elderly aid workers and care homes as
you've also highlighted were reportedly
told that they should not send anyone to
the hospital for intensive care even if
they were in critical condition you've
mentioned that you're launching a you
know a commission to look into the
strategy that you've also launched
additional measures but at the end of
the day it is too late for the families
who have lost loved ones it is too late
for it for those nearly five thousand
who have died so what do you say to them
well every death is very tragic and that
is of course nothing that we wanted to
have the coronavirus I don't think you
thought that in Germany - and I don't
think that anyone think that well this
is something that the government wants
for anybody and that's also the case for
our government we have really really
tried to work out the best strategy but
we have like several other countries
very high virus and transmission in a
regional part of Sweden that is
Stockholm and the areas around it and it
came in to the elderly care homes and
that is of course very very unfortunate
and that's why we have taken central
decision to make it better and that's
why we are now in a much better position
we don't have any exact death rate
anymore and it's going down also when it
comes to intensive care and people on
the the hospital which of course hope
will stay so that there will be no more
second wave we don't know what happened
this was a new virus to everybody I'd
like to talk with you about that
potential second wave because we have
had your chief epidemiologist saying the
following about the
for that Sweden will see more cases for
period but in the long term we hope
we'll have better control of the
pandemic he's also highlighted the fact
that in the autumn there will be a
second wave Sweden will have a high
level of immunity and the number of
cases will probably be quite low you
said you say you're in a better position
now but but ultimately I mean you do
have nearly 5,000 dead in the country
there is so little known about immunity
and kovat 19 so I'd just like to ask you
where where is your science or just
Sweden no more than than all of the
other leading researchers in the world
well I don't think anybody knows right
now about a possible of herd immunity or
how long an immunity should stay or if
there is a second wave or a third wave
or anything like that that is not
possible to say because it's the first
time in the history of the world that we
have this cough in nineteen pandemic we
have never had it before so we cannot
know about that there has been talk
though there has been hope for the first
vaccine perhaps being on the market by
the end of 2020 if trials go well the EU
already signing a deal with drug maker
AstraZeneca for four hundred million
doses have you considered that a vaccine
could come to the market so quickly and
and how do you consider that you might
be front-loading or at least with the
strategy you might have front-loaded
your human losses without having the
science to back up that it's a smart
move in the long run
well we have now put 2 billion Swedish
crown and the vaccine coordinator
because of course we hope that the
vaccine that comes will be a part of a
global common good and it will come to
those who deserve it most
but did you have the right science on
immunity well actually I'm a Minister of
Foreign Affairs so I don't know if we
have the right science of herd immunity
or whatever
and I hope that you will also interview
the epidemic released and the Minister
of Social Affairs to be more able to
discuss those issues I'd like to talk
about something that you have spoken
quite extensively on the the Swedish
coronavirus policy was designed on a
system of trust politicians authorities
the public you've spoken very highly
about the system of trust but but the
latest polls indicate that the following
about that level of trust that the
Swedish public has in your policy only
45 percent of Swedes have now a fairly
high or very high faith in the strategy
compared with 63 percent in April that
that's a pretty dramatic dip do you see
that as damaging to your relationship
with the public and you know the concept
of a stable and a and a sane and a
reasonable Sweden now that is not what
we talked about when we talk about trust
you have misunderstood it unfortunately
because when we talk about trust that is
if people are trusting the politicians
and the authorities in what measures
should be taken that is not legally
binding and still of the three months
more than 80% of the people of following
the recommendation and that is trust and
that is because the Swedish people know
that when recommendations come from
authorities that is not some tip that
you are supposed to follow or not you
should follow it and they do to more
than a degree of 80 percent that is the
trust that we are talking about and that
is very very good because for a long
time actually since the sixteenth
century it has been built on big
authorities small ministries it's the
advice and recommendation of authorities
combined with illegally binding measures
that is always taking form of a strategy
also this time and I'm very very proud
that so many Swedish people are actually
having a trusts of their
in recommendation then of course if they
have trust in the political parties or
so on that is a completely different
issue let's talk a little bit more about
the relationship that you have with your
neighbors right now the state of trust
they're your neighbors including Finland
Norway and Denmark are lifting travel
restrictions in the region but for the
most part they are excluding Sweden due
to its higher level of kovat 19
infections they have concerns they have
voiced them on record you traditionally
have excellent communication and
cooperation with your Nordic neighbours
so so leaving Sweden now it breaks with
a long-standing close cooperation you're
the Foreign Minister what do you think
about being isolated by your neighbors
right now well I'm so glad that we have
such an excellent Nordic cooperation
like we managed to repatriate
8600 switch from all over the world with
a very close a good Nordic operation we
have Minister of Foreign Affairs meeting
every week we had consular meetings with
our consular diplomats every day and we
had a very very close Nordic operation
managed to get everybody back home we
are also of course keeping that
cooperation now during the weekend I had
long talks with both my Norwegian and my
Danish colleague and I also have contact
with my Finnish colleague and for
example we are now hoping that everybody
will vote for Norway tomorrow so they
get a seat in the council a Security
Council in United Nations but one thing
that is not so very good is the border
cooperation where everybody who has been
living working having families across
the borders have been very very aware of
that we are different nations in for
example the north of Sweden between
haparanda Antonio it has been
practically like one town and suddenly
now when we hit differently by the
coronavirus border
closed and that will be wounds that will
take time to to heal how about the
wounds with your European partners we
also have the EU Home Affairs
Commissioner illy Johansson who also
happens to be Swedish she wants you
Member States to lift all border checks
within the block by the end of June as
we mentioned the European CDC their
assessment is that your wave of
transmission has not peaked yet so
that's not happening is it well we have
to see because that's the decision from
every country themself and every country
is doing what they think is best we have
since the beginning wanted to have a
coordinated in EU wide solution that
would have been the best but that has
shown it's not possible but I still I
mean I invite once I was in the
government together with me so we know
each other very well and we speak all
the time so I know very well that they
really want to have coordinated answer
and I think that would have been the
best because now every country has their
own reason for why they're lifting or
not lifting different border controls
and and that is not the best of the time
for you and for example different
countries they have export restrictions
Sweden did not have it and for example
the the the spare Spanish Prime Minister
said when we couldn't get our medical
equipment Sweden came and helped us to
get it free from countries who had put
export restriction also on medical and
let's talk about protective wear yeah
let's talk about that because you're
getting into the economic aspect of this
pandemic now the EU facing the worst
recession in its history it's exposing
risks between countries about how to
deal with that you've highlighted some
of them you highlighted on the export
front we have southern states like Italy
Spain they've been the hardest hit
they have pleaded for aid from the EU in
the form of grants and mutual eyes debt
a plea that you and three other nations
called The Frugal for
mostly in the blocks north opposed now
the EU of course it's a union that goes
far beyond the single market it's a
union of values your opinion identity
solidarity how should this project
survive if you and your frugal four
allies who together only represent less
than 10% of the EU population tell the
citizens of some of the largest
countries whose economies are literally
too big to fail that you won't support
your partners when they need help the
most well it sounds like you want to
throw us out of EU I don't think the
other countries want that I think that
he really really wants to stay in 27
countries and that is what we are
planning to do but of course we could
have differences when it comes to how
you should have restoring of the
economic and situation from our part we
have always said that there is a sound
and good economy as a basis of
everything and that is how also how we
are now reasoning we think that we
should have a recovery plan but we think
it should be done in a sound and
economically wise way and that is why we
think it should be just the measures
measures that is time-limited it should
be measures that is controlled and that
is what we will work for in and mff that
is the dhih budget discussion put it
together we are not against to have a
recovery plan not at all but we want to
do it in a responsible way so a
responsible in a sound way let's drill
down a little bit deeper into the
message that your group The Frugal floor
has been sending to your European
partners in need because after nine
countries including Italy and Spain as
we mentioned requested financial support
in the form of mutual eyes debt the
Dutch finance minister said the
following Brussels should study why some
governments lacked the financial
wherewithal to fight the crisis on their
own and in that context I would like to
ask you I mean it is now really the best
time to be taking the high ground
in a lesson in fiscal morality a time
when your partners need help well
actually I think that we should help
each other for example by keeping the
internal market totally open so you
don't put export restriction to anybody
that actually need help from other
countries Sweden has been one of the
country who has been most active when it
comes to ventilators all over Europe
when some other countries wanted to keep
them for themselves for their national
people we didn't do that we showed that
solidarity we also showed a lot of
solidarity by giving very very high
grants to World Health Organization the
United Nation the vaccine program
because we think this is a global
pandemic that we should fight globally
so you said that you have expressed a
sense of solidarity you know one of the
chief messages of those who support this
mix of grants and loans is that it does
indeed benefit all states in the EU for
example he says the the frugal countries
benefit disproportionately from the
single market and so should swing behind
the proposals and now this is coming
from the EU s budget commissioner who is
Austrian tell us
I mean Sweden is an export-based economy
over 70% of Swedish exports end up in
the EU if the single market burns so
does your economy so does he have a
point here yeah it's of course the
budgetary commissioner wants the EU to
have a much bigger budget he was not he
would not do his job if he didn't have
that view but we are saying the same
thing we are always saying we think that
EU should have a sound economy we don't
think it should be too much loans and we
don't think it should be utilized that
is actually now it's against the treaty
of EU to have mute alized load so this
next weekend's negotiation amongst
leaders will of course be very very
interesting
and we I don't think that they are
supposed to take the decision now but it
will be much clearer in what way it will
be possible to go to get a recovery plan
but not to put yappity on the EU's
economy I'd like to ask you because one
one of the areas that has come up when
we're talking about Jeopardy for the EU
economy is this issue of inequality and
unequal recovery miracle and macron have
warned that allowing some EU countries
to recover faster and some stronger
would only deepen inequalities in the
bloc hampering the way the trade
operates internally funder Lyon has also
stressed that it's crucial for the
recovery to be even so you even have the
fiscally conservative Germans
recognising the need for grants in the
recovery fund aren't you forcing a more
unequal Europe with your approach where
is the Solidarity where is the urgency I
I think that more unequal EU is nothing
that anybody want and not to have an
equality inside country that's why I
hope that many more countries would
follow our example to have a tax system
that is more equalizing the possibility
for people to have the same
possibilities both when it comes to job
to education and to pay more for
therefore the common goods and that is
something I think should be a national
thing and there is a lot to discuss
there when it comes to equality inside
and between countries and I don't think
Sweden is the country to blame here what
is your vision then of the EU post
corona
I mean if the EU can't rise to the
challenge now and use this moment for
further integration further solidarity
further consensus coming together when
it's really facing this massive public
health crisis and the greatest economic
challenge since it was created then when
when when will it become a stronger
union well EU has been managing so many
crises during the whole lifetime of you
am i quite sure that you will manage it
managing this crisis as well
and it will take some time to go back to
to the economy to the free borders to
the internal market but we will manage
as we have done always I am not afraid
of that that's nothing I worry about
Swedish foreign minister and Linda thank
you for joining us on complex on thank
you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]